ANDY CHANG: Hi, and
welcome to SEC 212, where
we'll cover how you can
take control of security
with the Security
Command Center.
I'm Andy Cheng, a product
manager in Google's Cloud
Security team.
And I'm here with my
co-presenter, Kyle Olive.
KYLE OLIVE: Hi.
I'm Kyle Olive, a product
manager on the Google Cloud
Security Command Center team.
ANDY CHANG: Kyle
will be covering
some of the built-in
vulnerability
and threat detectors in
detail later in this talk.
In addition, we'll
be showing you
an example of how Veolia, a
multinational based in France,
operating utilities, water and
waste management, and energy
services, has integrated
Security Command Center
into their security workflow.
Staying in control of
your security is hard.
As cloud adoption grows and
your teams get even more agile,
the accelerated velocity
of cloud development
means that you have increasing
numbers of dynamic resources
and services being deployed,
expanding your attack surface
and potentially expanding
both the risks that you
have to address and the scale
and complexity of your estate.
Traditional tools
needed also seem
to endlessly multiply
and make it hard
for you to drive consistency
and get one unified view
of your security posture.
As enterprises move
from on-premise
to public cloud environments,
three common concerns
are top of mind.
How do I get full visibility?
And how do I get an
accurate assessment
of my attack surface,
my security posture,
and my compliance state?
Can I continue to
detect and respond
to the threats that are most
relevant and important to me?
How do I learn to use and deal
with the additional complexity
of new architectures, policy
systems, technologies,
and the services available
in public clouds?
And across all three
of these, how do I
keep on top of all
of these things
as the scope of services
and the size of deployments
from my teams continually
grows and increases?
Finally, will I need to know how
to manage an ever-growing set
of security tools with disparate
interfaces and capabilities
in order to keep ahead
of these challenges?
Or can I use something
native and built in?
Security Command Center
provides you a single place
to control the security of
your estate on Google Cloud.
Security Command Center
offers a unified set
of capabilities that enables
you consistent and continuous
organization-wide
visibility, detection,
and enables you to respond
all from one place,
leveraging the best of Google
Cloud Security expertise
with all the services managed
by Google and at Google scale.
Security Command Center Premium
addresses your challenges
by providing you
with a single place
for organizational-level
control over the built-in threat
prevention and threat
detection capabilities offered
by Google Cloud.
From one unified place,
you can manage and review
findings related
to your security
posture, your active threats,
the underlying assets being
impacted and their metadata,
and the different types
and classifications of
data potentially at risk,
all through a Google-managed
system that automatically
scales and deploys with the
growth of your organization.
Security Command Center offers a
single consistent place for you
to enable which
security services should
be enabled where.
By default, all resources
supported by Security Command
Center are automatically
monitored and covered
by threat prevention and
detection capabilities.
So as your developers
spin up new projects
and your organization
grows, these policies
get applied
automatically, reducing
the danger of an
inadvertent blind spot
in your understanding
of your attack surface.
With Security Command
Center Premium,
you can continuously monitor
your security posture,
monitor your asset
configurations
against common misconfigurations
and against compliance controls
like CIS and PCI.
You can automatically
detect vulnerabilities
in your public web applications
from the OWASP Top 10.
And in addition, you
can detect and protect
against active threats through
real time log and cluster
analysis to find bad actors
and stop them in real time.
I'll now turn it over
to Kyle to provide you
details on each of these
built-in capabilities.
KYLE OLIVE: Keeping
your deployments secure
is an ongoing challenge.
But as Andy mentioned,
Security Command Center
includes several
capabilities that
help you increase your
scope of coverage,
understand your
security posture,
and enable you to become
more secure over time.
We'll spend a little
bit of time going over
each of these
capabilities before diving
into a real life
demonstration of how
you can use Security Command
Center in your organization.
First, let's talk
about the capabilities
designed to help you
understand and improve
your security posture.
Security Health Analytics
monitors and analyzes
your infrastructure
configurations
for known insecure
and configurations
that are not complying
with compliance controls.
Security Health Analytics
offers a broad scope
of coverage out-of-box and
with minimal configuration.
You simply turn
it on for your org
and get coverage for any
existing or any new projects
that get spun up.
Our goal with Security
Health Analytics
is to cover the broader scope
of Google Cloud Services,
leveraging Google security
know-how to provide detections
and recommendations that
will make customers more
secure across Storage, Compute,
and several other Google Cloud
Services.
Every detection
includes the metadata
you need to triage that finding
and act on it, including
context-specific
remediation instructions.
Additionally, we have recently
improved Security Health
Analytics to have an
even tighter integration
with your resource
configurations,
detecting changes in
configurations in real time
and allowing you to react and
respond to critical events
before a breach can occur.
Security Health
Analytics can detect
some of the most impactful
misconfigurations,
like public buckets
or open firewalls,
while also providing
more nuanced security
recommendations around
networking, logging,
and monitoring.
These recommendations come
from our security teams.
And many of them are
the same guidelines that
Google itself puts into place.
The selection of
detections found here
are only a small subset of
the total number of detections
that are available.
And that scope of coverage will
continue to increase over time.
One of the most exciting
things we've added this year
is the ability for
Security Health Analytics
to perform continuous compliance
monitoring, identifying
resources that are known
to be misconfigured
against compliance controls from
the CIS GCP benchmark, PCI-DSS,
ISO 27001, NIST
800-53, and more.
These findings are
surfaced through dashboards
that can be filtered and
scoped by projects or folders,
giving you control over how
you assess your environment.
These reports can be a starting
point for remediative actions
or exported out
as a CSV that can
be used to track your
compliance state over time.
But your security posture
is made up of more than just
your resource configurations.
It's also important to monitor
against vulnerabilities
in your web applications.
Security Command Center
includes Web Security Scanner
for that purpose.
Web Security Scanner
automatically detects and scans
your exposed public
web applications
for the most common and
impactful vulnerabilities found
in web apps.
Like Security Health
Analytics, there
is minimal configuration
overhead required here.
You just turn on the service,
and Security Command Center
will automatically
detect and configure
web application scans for apps
running on GAE, GKE, or GCE.
These scans will crawl your
public web applications
in order to detect some of the
most severe vulnerabilities
found in web applications,
including vulnerabilities
from categories of the OWASP Top
10, like cross-site scripting
and security misconfigurations.
These, again, are the
same tools that Google
uses to protect and scan
our own web applications.
And we're making
these detections
available to Security
Command Center customers.
All of the findings
we just talked about
can be centrally managed from
the vulnerabilities dashboard
or via a single Security
Command Center API.
Each finding is associated
with the severity
and other additional
metadata, allowing
you to assess the potential
impact of the finding
and triage it for action.
Finally, as mentioned,
each finding
includes context-specific
remediation instructions
that you can quickly
act on yourself,
automate against, or
copy into a ticket
that you can assign
to a project owner.
But sometimes, despite
all our best efforts,
malicious actors
manage to compromise
some part of a deployment.
Security Command Center
also provides you
the tools you need to
detect these intrusions
and respond to
them in real time.
First up, we have
Event Threat Detection.
At Google, we have dedicated
threat intelligence groups
analyzing activities on
the internet for the latest
threat signals, not only
to protect ourselves,
but also our customers.
Event Threat Detection
leverages those threat
signals to provide an
enhanced level of detection,
allowing you to
catch more incidents.
These detections
happen in real time
as soon as the log is generated,
allowing you to respond
to incidents in seconds.
As your logs are generated,
Event Threat Detection
monitors them, analyzing
entries from your audit
logs, your syslogs,
and your network logs.
From there, we apply
our detection logic
and use Google's
threat intelligence
to identify malicious
actors performing one
of several types of activities.
Event Threat Detection
can detect activities
related to malware or coin
mining running on your systems.
It can detect active data
exfiltration or IAM abuse,
and will be able to leverage
user behavior analytics
to detect compromises
on accounts
and alert you to that activity.
And the scope of
these detections
will only increase over time.
Google's expertise can also
be leveraged in other ways,
like with our Container
Threat Detection capabilities
now in Security Command Center.
Container Threat Detection
is an exciting new capability
available in Security
Command Center.
At its core, it's a Linux
Security Module baked
into COS and GKE that can detect
incidents occurring on your GKE
workloads in real time.
Once again, Security
Command Center
handles the management
of these deployments,
automatically enabling Container
Threat Detection on clusters
and projects per your settings
as soon as those clusters get
spun up, removing the
overhead that regularly comes
with this kind of protection.
Once enabled, Container
Threat Detection
monitors real-time
changes on your workloads
to detect incidents like the
execution of added binaries,
new linked libraries, or
when a cluster suddenly
opens a reverse shell
to the internet,
all signs of a compromise.
In just seconds, you
can alert on an incident
and even take automated
action against it.
For an example of
that, we'll now
switch over to a demo
from Guillaume Blaquiere.
At Veolia.
Guillaume will walk us
through how Veolia leverages
Security Command Center to
respond to vulnerabilities
automatically in real
time in a way that
can be extended to
any of the detections
we just talked about.
Let's take a look.
GUILLAUME BLAQUIERE:
Hi, everyone.
I'm Guillaume Blaquiere.
I'm [INAUDIBLE] expert
on Cloud Platform.
I'm also a cloud master and
Lead Architect at Veolia.
Veolia is a major
French company,
a [INAUDIBLE] company focused
on water, waste, and energy,
present in 50
countries in the world
and with more than
170,000 employees.
Veolia work with more than
seven years with Google Cloud.
And today we have more
than 4,000 projects
on GCP with internal
and external people
and partners that work on
the platform for building
and solutions in production.
Today, managing the security
is a challenge for us,
because we are a
small team in Paris.
And we have a lot of people, a
lot of countries, several time
zones, several different
affinities with the security.
And we have a lot of work to do.
For example, when we have
to review the firewalls
and to see what is
open too widely,
we perform batches
every three months.
And we review all the firewalls.
We contact the project owner to
review with them if it's normal
or not that you have this
rule and so on and to fix it
or to [INAUDIBLE] these rules?
It's a lot of work
every three months.
It's not very interesting.
It's time consuming.
And we perform this
only every three months.
And in three months, it
can happen a lot of things.
Now, with Security
Command Center,
every event in the cloud are
scanned by the Security Command
Center.
And when the findings is found,
it is published on Pub/Sub.
And the message is
consumed by Cloud Run.
In turn, we have implemented
two actions on the message.
The first one is to
publish a message in Slack.
The second one is to use the
Google API for immediate action
on the finding, for
example, to revoke
some authorization on a bucket.
We have in our road map
to implement other things,
for example, to send an
email on the findings,
to open a ticket
in our ticketing
tool, servicenow, at Veolia.
And we can also store
only the real finding
for Veolia and then to build
a dashboard on these findings.
And at the end, we can provide
a global view on the security
to the security team, to the
managers, to the auditors,
and so on.
So now I would like
to present to you
a demo of what we have done
today with the Security Command
Center.
And here, I have
the firewall rules.
Just go under Findings here.
We are in the landing
page for the findings.
And we can filter by security.
But my preferred view is
here, the Findings Changed.
Why?
Because you can see what is new.
What are the new findings
in your environment,
in your context, the last hour,
the last day, the last week,
and so on?
It's very efficient
for working with this.
So now imagine I
have a user that
would like to share
some documents
with a customer and partners.
There's a lot of
people involved.
And the user don't want
to grant all the users one
by one in the console.
For this, user want to
make the bucket public
and to share it widely.
At Veolia, we don't
want this, because we
consider that the data stored in
our buckets are Veolia's data.
And these are confidential data.
And we don't want to
share it with anybody.
That way, we can
apply for example,
an organization policy
named domain [INAUDIBLE]
that prevents you
to grant all users
and all authenticated
users to the buckets.
But the side effect of
this organization policy
is you can't grant all users
and all authenticated users
to Cloud Run, [INAUDIBLE],,
and App Engine.
And that way, with this
organization policy,
we can't make public
our API and our website.
Or we can whitelist a project
for making public our API
and our website
[INAUDIBLE] App Engine.
But we also whitelist
our bucket and can't
grant all users and
all authenticated users
to the buckets.
And we don't want this.
Now with Security Command Center
and the [INAUDIBLE] findings,
we can do this.
For example, here
I have a bucket.
And I would like
to share publicly
this [INAUDIBLE] bucket.
I will add all users here.
And I will share all the
objects of my bucket.
When I save, I have
a warning message.
And I'll say, now
your bucket is public.
And yes, say, OK.
I'm aware of this.
And a finding is found by
Security Command Center.
A message is published
to the [INAUDIBLE]..
And our [INAUDIBLE] instance
publish a message on Slack.
Hey, you have a finding here.
And we removed automatically
the authorization of the bucket.
We can go back to the bucket.
You can see here, it's
publicly accessible.
But in fact not--
if I refresh the
page, the bucket--
the authorization has
been removed automatically
by calling the Google API.
So now we don't have a problem,
only two or three seconds
between the public
access and the revocation
by the [INAUDIBLE] instance.
Same thing, for example,
with the firewall rules--
I would like to use
Veolia's resources
in my professional account to
build a [INAUDIBLE] Minecraft
server for playing with
my friends and my family.
And I've created a compute
instance, deployed my Minecraft
instance.
And now I have to
create firewall rules.
So I would create
firewall rules.
[INAUDIBLE] here, I can name it.
If I'm stupid, I
name it Minecraft.
But I'm stupid.
And I can allow all the
instances of network.
I open it very widely,
because my friends, my family,
and a lot of people--
and I would like to open
it on the port 10,000,
because my server [INAUDIBLE].
Now, I will click on Create.
And as before, in a few
seconds, I can see here
in the Slack Channel, oh,
you have an open firewalls
findings.
And I don't know what to do.
I don't know if it's
normal or not normal.
And I can ask the
security team do
to a review on these findings.
Why?
Because when you have a bucket
open publicly on the internet,
you can immediately
download the contents,
and the data leak is instant.
When you open a strange
port on firewall rules,
maybe some intruder can use
it and enter into the system.
But it's not instant.
It can take days, weeks,
or months for this.
And you can take more
time to review the rules.
And now I can see
what's happened.
I click on the link.
And I can see, oh, I have
a rule named Minecraft
open on internet on this port.
No, it's not normal.
I have to delete it.
And now it's--
I can react immediately
on firewalls open.
And I don't have to perform
batches every three months
as before.
Now the platform is more secure.
It's quicker to
react on the events.
With the premium version, we
have more and more findings.
And we can fine-tune what we'd
like to allow and to disallow
on our platform.
And it's helped us a lot
in our day-to-day job.
It's less boring as before.
So this evolution and this
real-time notification
is very, very great
for us at Veolia.
Thank you.
ANDY CHANG: As Guillaume
showed in the demo,
Veolia has been able to
integrate Security Command
Center Premium into
its security workflow
and remove the toil
of batch assessments
for vulnerability, to moving
to a continuous vulnerability
assessment with
proactive alerting.
Security Command Center Premium
addresses the challenges
of giving you the continuous
visibility of your security
posture across your
ever-changing asset estate
that you need.
It provides you near real-time
detection of vulnerabilities
and of threats that
can impact your system.
And it reduces the
complexity and toil
for you to protect your estate
and maintain a strong security
posture on Google Cloud.
Security Command Center Premium
is provided through an annual
all-you-can-use subscription,
which empowers you to have
your security scale
with your growth,
regardless of how large
your organization grows.
To learn more about Security
Command Center Premium,
please go to
cloud.google.com/security
command center.
Now, let's bring Kyle back.
We'd like to thank you so much
for the opportunity you gave
us to present to you how you can
take control of your security
with the Cloud Security
Command Center.
KYLE OLIVE: Thanks for watching.